ich glaube mich selbst einschätzen zu
können dass ich mit diesem immensen
druck der sich zeitlich temporär
entwickelt hat auf dauer nicht umgehen
kann als verfolgt
ich denke dass ich mit dem ich habe mich
wieder vergessen wann der voll kluger
mann
ich sitze blöd hey leute und herzlich
willkommen zu einem kleinen info video
bzw die lok die lok war ja sonst immer
eigentlich dass sich dann mit dem
gesicht vor der kamera war und das ist
auch schon genau das thema und zwar geht
es um face cam und es geht allgemein
real live videos ich habe mich ja vor ca
wann war das vor drei monaten oder vor
vier monaten glaube ich gezeigt und hab
dann regelmäßig eigentlich immer so die
face kemmann gemacht was mir natürlich
auch spaß gemacht hat was euch auch spaß
gemacht hat was ihr auch sehr gefeiert
hat und was sie auch sehr gut findet
weil wir dadurch emotionen besser sehen
könnt ihr könnt sehen wie ich mich fühle
wie ich zum beispiel aussehe und so was
alles hat natürlich alles raus gefunden
und könnte mit mir jetzt auch eine
person verbinden die quasi hinter diesem
computer sitzen diese videos für euch
dreht allerdings ist es dieser personen
letzter zeit alles ein bisschen zu sehr
zu kopf gestiegen was hier an nicht
kritik sondern an ein rückgabe der
quantitativen sehr quantitativ gesehen
sehr hohem masse an zuschauern
eingeprasselt ist und zwar möchte ich
jetzt erstmal ab jetzt keine videos mehr
machen die alten bleiben natürlich
hauptsächlich eigentlich erst mal alle
bestehen und das ist ganz einfach aus
dem grund bevor jetzt daumen runter geht
dass ich zurzeit mich in einer ich
nochmal phase
das hätte ich so gerne hilft in einer
phase wo ich etwas und das denke und ich
bin von der midlife crisis
na ja also ich bin zurzeit in so einer
phase ist eigentlich das passende wort
aber ich fühle mich zur zeit nicht
einfach so als wird mir das alles zu
kopf steigen
dieser komplette internet diese
komplette internet pseudo berühmtheit
auf mehrfach im wege also sei es über
facebook youtube instagram alle
möglichen sozialen netzwerke jetzt weg
das war mir magen falls das geld das er
gemacht musste ich gerade mal kurz mich
übergeben
jedenfalls ist es für mich zurzeit so
dass ich einfach denke 260.000 leute
oder ich glaube sogar noch mehr ich weiß
ich also zum zeitpunkt dieses video wo
ich das gerade aufnehmen ist der zwölfte
juni 2013
und es kann sein dass das video erst in
zwei wochen kommt oder so und ich mir
vielleicht auch noch anders überlege
oder essen zwei wochen das hochladen
werde oder vielleicht auch schon morgen
ich weiß es nicht jedenfalls lade ich es
wird wahrscheinlich der dreizehnte sein
woher dieses video seht allerdings wird
in zukunft erst mal keine face comeback
kommen und es werden auch erst mal keine
reale videos bekommen ich weiß jetzt
werden alle möglichen leute jetzt mal
daumen runter geben allerdings die die
jetzt ein daumen runter geben bitte geht
das ist echt nett gemeint bitte ich
möchte nicht solche abonnenten haben die
mich nur abonniert haben weil ich da
face cam videos gemacht hat bzw
live-videos die meisten meiner
abonnenten waren schon vorher da ohne
dass sie mein gesicht kann und wenn ihr
mich jetzt die abonnieren weil ich keine
fans gerne machen wir das total hier
richtig wenn ihr das von mir aus machen
wollt dann gebt daumen runter und geht
dann aber bitte auch nicht einfach
daumen runter geben hätten so von wegen
warum macht jetzt keine fußgänger ist er
voll ranzig und weil dann okay ich euch
weil das verstehe ich nicht warum ihr
das nicht akzeptiert und zwar hat sagt
dir du kannst mit kritik ja gar nicht
umgehen doch kann ich und in letzter
zeit ist es echt so gewesen dass ihr das
sehr gefeiert hat mit der face cam und
euch die noch viel öfter gewünscht habt
allerdings stellt versetze ich mal meine
lage es sind 160 tausend leute ich sag
mal jugendliche bzw die kinder sind der
mehr oder weniger als in der 12 13
jährige die meine videos gucken was das
ganze wenn ein bisschen schlimmer macht
weil die noch keine erfahrung haben und
halt sehr sehr kindlich sich noch
verhalten und wenn ich das ganze wissen
so ausgeprägt ist dass sie sich
vielleicht an andere personen an der
gefühlslage verein hineinversetzen
können
stellt euch mal vor 160 tausend leute
wissen wie ihr ausseht wenn ich sogar
noch wenn mein erstes video
konkret an real life blogger 240.000
aufrufe das ist eine viertelmillion das
ist so unglaublich viel ihr glaubt es
nicht
stellt euch mal vor ich würde jetzt auf
eine messe gehen wie zb die gamescom
das ist ja so die größte messe da wo
quasi der die größte die einzige messe
in deutschland wo das meiste publikum
mich quasi kennen sollte bzw kennen wird
und ich laut struber dann verfolgen mich
doch übels viele leute beziehen wir
wollen autogramme und mir ist es ja
jetzt schon kopfe gestiegen als mit
letztes einer stadt erkannt hat und dann
etwas größeren stadt war ich da in der
stadt der kander und gerade bis zu
crafter und ich sehe damit kam ich schon
fast nicht klar ich möchte nicht so die
person sein die mittelpunkt steht und wo
außen rum dass die leute stehen
autogramme wollen leute wie sarrazin
gespielt viele weitere kommen damit
prima klar das respektiere ich auch und
darauf dafür habe ich auch recht großen
respekt und verneige mich verlieren dass
dies wirklich so aushalten können
aber ich fühle mich einfach so mit jedem
video was ich mehr machen wo ich mich
zeige gebe ich mehr von mir frei sage
ich mal also ihr seht immer neue updates
wie sehe ich aus
ihr bekommt mein gesicht quasi ein
gespeichert und wenn ihr täglich sagen
wir mal wetten dass wird täglich laufen
ihr hätte damals täglich werden dass
geguckt oder guckt immer wetten dass ihr
wisst wie thomas gottschalk aussieht
oder allgemein die ganzen profis wenn
ihr die auf der straße sieht erkennt ihr
die ob ihr die anspricht oder nicht dass
es egal ist wer das ist und ihr wert den
das komische blicke zu mit solchen
blicken komme ich nicht klar
ich weiß nicht ich mag das überhaupt
nicht wenn wir leute irgendwie so
komischen daher gucken das heißt oder
dann irgendwie auf mich an quatschen
oder so ich möchte das einfach nicht und
es wird schlussendlich darauf
hinauslaufen dass das resultieren teil
passieren wird und das möchte ich halt
so ein bisschen einschränken sag ich mal
deswegen die meisten reallife videos
werden erst mal auf meinen kanal bleiben
ich möchte auch nicht dass ihr euch
jetzt irgendwelche videos oder fotos von
hier runterladen
und irgendwann das hochladen und dann
sagt so höre jetzt controller
die meisten wissen noch wie ich aussehe
aber ich werde einfach keine neuen
videos mit machen das heißt ihr werdet
die veränderung von mir in meiner person
von meinen haaren von meinem gesicht her
nicht feststellen können
ich möchte einfach ganz diskret jetzt
internet vorgehen und einfach so eine
art zensur seine zensur ist schon wieder
zu krass hin so sagt jetzt jeder also
ich möchte mich bisschen zensieren und
zwar viel viel mehr an die privatsphäre
gehen ich mache videos für euch was da
ich beantworte natürlich auch noch
fragen uns was alles aber ich habe jetzt
auch account geschlossen ich habe
twitter bin ich auch drauf und dran das
zu schließen aber tritt das eigentlich
gar nicht so schlimm aber ich möchte so
ein bisschen von diesen ganzen plattform
weg gehen ich mache videos für euch ich
poste bei facebook news und das war es
eigentlich schon und vielmehr möchte ich
auch nicht sein ich bin hier eine person
die macht das auch spaß und es ist in
letzter zeit wirklich so dass hatte den
rauch gesagt in seinem den astag davon
bevor er nach mallorca geflogen das hat
er gesagt ja da habe ich jetzt ein
bisschen was vorgenommen und da habe ich
jetzt am neuen kanal gemacht wohl
einfach das thema sein wird ich noch
videos wenn ich bock hab also das
grundprinzip von youtube von anfang an
eigentlich darüber habe ich dann auch
mal eine menge nachgedacht und zwar bin
ich auch mit dem gedanken auf youtube
gekommen
videos machen da hätte ich eigentlich
schon bock dran
nach und nach kamen dann so anfragen von
youtube ob ich dein partner werden wir
nun ich dachte so sind dass partner
ich mache das aus spaß 20 cent leicht
ersparen und dann nach und nach wurden
diese einnahmen mehr oder weniger
veröffentlichter neuem ich gesehen dass
man damit nicht schon ne menge geld
verdienen kann und so weiter und so fort
und hab da noch eine menge leute bei
youtube kennengelernt und es macht
natürlich immer noch spaß sonst würde
ich überhaupt nicht machen weil ich
finde wenn man in etwas wenn man spaß an
etwas hat dann hat man grundsätzlich
auch erfolg also spaß plus beruf gleich
erfolg es ist einfach so oder hobby plus
beruf gleich spaß das ist einfach so
wenn man ein hobby hatte das zum beruf
macht dann macht das spaß und man möchte
es immer weitermachen und so ist das bei
mir nur bei mir ist das so ich möchte
nicht gezwungen sein jetzt juli live
videos für euch zu machen weil ich damit
jetzt einmal angefangen habe nach dem
zweiten block welche lüth youtuber ich
gucke kamen übel viele leute nach zwei
wochen so hieß der dritte wiederwahl mit
einem live video sehen so was alles und
auch bei facebook um fragen habt immer
hat immer gewonnen ja ich will neue live
video von dir haben ist ja schön und gut
akzeptiere ich auch ich kann das auch
nachvollziehen dass in eurer videos von
mir haben wollte aber versetzt euch doch
mal meine
tage und zwar bin ich dann ja quasi
gezwungen diese mobile video zu machen
bei minecraft videos ist das anders da
kann ich so viel machen wie ihr wollt
weil da gebe ich nicht zum milchpreis
nichts über mich frei preisgeben
freigeben das gleiche aber wenn ich die
serie live videos mache dann seht ihr
immer wie ich aussehe
und das ist einfach so eine sache wenn
nämlich auf der straße sieht oder wenn
stemmer vor ihr läuft über die straße
und vielleicht finde dass einige von
euch wenn sie angesprochen werden und
die ganzen tag x 13 13 jährige leute
dann auch auf euch zukommen jetzt nichts
gegen 13-jährige aber vor allem die
person die halt dann keinen respekt
haben und dann einfach auf euch zu
laufen so euch dann verfolgen zu müssen
oder so wenn ich eine zuschauerschaft
hätte die 20 jahre plus wäre dann wäre
das eigentlich kein problem weil die
würden auf mich zukommen so hey du bist
doch kontra finde ich klasse was machst
ja bla bla
und ja das ist so ein bisschen da hat
man respekt aber die 13-jährigen diesen
anlass diesen anders diese nach anders
nein also das sind jetzt auch nicht nur
13 auf 24 aber das ist jetzt das ist
halt einfach so das ist macht die natur
so dass ihr die kinder von anfang von
geburt an sage ich mal sich bis ins
alter bis 18 jahre 20 jahre für die
entwicklung vor bei vermeintlich erst
mit 40
da wird man erwachsener
verständnisvoller versteht die welt mehr
ich glaube meine mutter gegen promi
sehen würde
oder sagen wir meinen opa oder irgendwie
so dürfen sie sich angucken wir denken
fernsehen super cool weitergehen aber
wenn irgendwelche übelsten fans von
denen die sehen würden wie zb wenn
mädels auf in justin bieber konzert und
die justin bieber dann schreit und
greift die rum wie sonst was uns dort
den und verfolgt den und alles und
knutschen ab und ich würde nicht sagen
dass es bei mir auch so werde es wäre
auf jeden fall eher so als wie wenn da
das opfer beispiel ist kurz und knackig
gesagt ich glaube mich selbst
einschätzen zu können dass ich mit
diesem immensen druck der sich zeitlich
temporär entwickelt hat auf dauer nicht
umgehen kann alter ersatzflug ja ich
denke dass ich mit dem ich habe mich
wieder vergessen wann der verfolgt man
blöd er gut also freundlich hoffe ihr
habt mich verstanden und werdet mich
verstehen alle die idee abonnieren
wollen die d abonnieren jetzt bitte es
kann auch sein dass ich in einer mine
dass ich in einem monat wieder anfangen
die ersten fans kämpfen dann wieder zu
drehen aber zurzeit erst mal nicht ich
denke ich werde mich erst mal mit der
kamera an so ein paar projekte setzen
die ich schon auf dauer mal geplant
hatte und zwar erstmals objektiv kauf
und anhalt immer weiter in die rubrik
film film produktion zu gehen also mehr
filme zu drehen und die eventuelle
manchmal hochzuladen
aber facetime technisch und soviel real
life wird nicht kommen mehr auf meinem
kanal auch bei instagram erstmal nicht
mehr so viele bilder von mir selber bzw
fast gar keine mehr
ich möchte also eine kleine rezension
einführen aufgrund vorgenommener
erlebnisse die ich in meinem
freundeskreis mitbekommen habe das war
hat jetzt nichts mit konkreter zu tun
das war einfach was anderes wenn das
einer von meinen freunden sehen wird
wird er vielleicht wissen sie meine ich
glaube aber nicht weil das andere
freundeskreis war da ist jedenfalls was
passiert wegen internet blau und das
möchte ich nicht er hat nicht näher
darauf eingehen
allerdings hat mir das so ein bisschen
die augen geöffnet sage ich mal
und ich meine wenn es irgendwann soweit
kommen sollte dass ich dann irgendwie
weise nicht 500.000 abonnenten hab ich
möchte jetzt nicht irgendwie arrogant
wirken oder so aber es wird mit der zeit
irgendwann so sein und es werden immer
mehr werden und immer mehr sehen weil
meine visage und werden mich dann auf
der straße erkennen und die altersgruppe
die wir zwar älter aber es kommen auch
immer wieder neue fans zuschauer sage
ich mir dazu und die entwickeln sich da
mehr oder weniger zu fans zuschauer
entwickelte sich zu den regal
jedenfalls hoffe ich dass ihr das recht
respektiert dass ich erst mal mit
facetime aufhören weil ich das ganze so
ein bisschen ein rahmen möchte in ich
bin an minecraft gaming kanal und kein
realitäts kanal und ich denke dass sich
temporär gesehen mit dem immensen druck
der durch die quanten quantenphysik die
komme ich denn jetzt auf quantenphysik
durch die quantitative masse wirklich
die immens hoch ist also qualitativ
gesehen ist die mensa ist dass ich damit
zeitlich gesehen nicht umgehen kann und
ich allgemeine ich die person die gerne
mittelpunkt steht also ich kann mich
artikulieren ich kann überzeugen ich
kann auch gut einfach so frei reden
referat bin ich auch überhaupt nicht
es denkt nicht jetzt irgendwie dass ich
wenn ich vor euch steht total schüchtern
bin oder so das bin ich ganz im
gegenteil eigentlich bin komplett
gegenteilige typ wert auf wahrscheinlich
in die richtung gehen dass ich mit
menschen interagieren werde ich dass da
einfach ihnen viel spaß dran haben und
das haben wir auch schon leute nach dem
referat gesagt dass ich mal lehramt
studieren soll oder irgendwie sowas oder
so was in die richtung halt einen
anderen menschen sowie vorträge halten
oder so haben auch lehrer schon gesagt
also daran liegt es nicht sondern es
liegt wirklich daran dass ich nicht
glaube ich in solchen situationen nicht
wohl fühlen werde wo dann leute auf mich
zukommen und sagen hey du bist doch
konkreter geht mein autogramm oder
möchten mich umarmt vor allem wenn ich
da mit freundinnen oder freunden oder
irgendwie so wenn ich habe keine
freundin
wenn ich dann aber wenn ich eine
freundin habe und dann irgendwie so im
laufe dann kommt der anderen mädels an
und um haben mich zum beispiel ob das
handy auch nicht so toll also versetzt
euch bitte einfach mal in meine lage das
wird mir schon sehr sehr weiterhelfen
das machen würde auch wenn ihr jetzt
sagt jan luca ich hab dich wegen daniela
videos abonniert und gucke auch lehrer
die von dir dass du mir jetzt echt leid
aber ich würde ich die abonnieren dann
macht das überhaupt nichts und dürfte
das ruhig gerne machen ich kann euch
auch nicht von abhalten
aber ich möchte nur dass ihr wisst dass
das für mich erstmal zu zeit zu viel
wird ich habe auch schon echt in letzter
zeit gedacht komplett mit youtube
aufzuhören weil die lust weg war während
der klausurphase und weil ich einfach
total ausgelaugt war ich hatte nie zeit
ich hatte niemals fünf minuten zeit mich
einfach am pc zu setzen im pc war
teilweise echt drei tage hintereinander
aus dass ich hab echt wenig zeit zu zeit
wenn ich irgendwas falsch gezeigt wird
bald ist klausurphase wieder vorbei dann
werde ich mir wieder ein paar videos
letzten liedern oktober wenn also matt
reviews die previews blitz aber real
life technisch erstmal nicht gibt ihm
auch stefan block wird weitergeführt und
also dass das ganze so ein bisschen
einschüchtern möchte verringern möchte
sage ich mal ich hoffe ihr respektiert
meine meinung akzeptiert dass und
respektiert mich weiterhin als personen
abo darf gerne bestehen bleiben wenn ihr
das nicht wollt dürft auch gerne die
abonnieren ich würde gern gerade einfach
weiter quatschen weil ich gerade drin im
thema durch davon überzeugen möchte dass
ihr quasi mich versteht aber ich denke
die meisten unter euch werden mich
verstehen und alle die rom hätten oder
kritik schreiben oder irgendwie sowas
bitte antwortet den einfach vernünftig
nicht direkt beleidigen und darüber
werde ich bald auch noch mal wieder
machen
über diese umgangsweise wie hier im
internet mit personen umgegangen wird
mobbing an sich etc halt aufgrund
vergangener erlebnisse nicht auf mich
bezogen sondern auf andere personen die
ich halt auch so über youtube nicht
kennengelernt habe sondern in den
kommentaren war immer sehr wie man die
person fertig gemacht werden weil das
ist echt schon teilweise sehr krass ich
möchte jetzt auch nicht hier die
moralapostel spielen aber es werden
videos kommen zur rechtschreibung oder
also zur rechtschreibung wie hier auf
youtube geschrieben wird und das alles
also dass man wirklich
wir befinden uns hier immer noch im
internet nicht alles was ihr schreibt
kann jeder sehen deswegen passt auf dass
ihr da nicht leute beleidigt oder dass
ihr euch übels aus dem rahmen sprengt
mit eurer grammatik und rechtschreibung
alles artikel endlich vernünftig wie ihr
euch nochmal mit einer person
unterhalten würde und dann können wir
ganz normal friedlich zusammen
diskutieren
aber so ist erst mal der stand dass ich
keine reality das bewachen werde es kann
sein dass es in zukunft wieder welche
geben wird aber das ist auf jeden fall
erstmal ein statement dazu und dann
hoffe ich dass ihr das akzeptiert ihr
dürften entweder mit daumen hoch oder
daumen runter bewerten es wird vielmehr
darunter als daumen hoch bekommen wenn
mich keiner verstehen wird ich hoffe
natürlich einige mich trotzdem
verstanden
wer nämlich verstanden habe dann danke
und ja wir sehen uns dann in folgenden
minecraft videos